[Musik]
was für ein Schuss was für ein Treffer
Kostja ist 34 und Kapitän einer ganz
besonderen Mannschaft alle haben als
Soldaten an der Front gekämpft alle
haben Beine oder Arme verloren Fußball
spielen sie
trotzdem sie sehen wir passen uns an wir
haben einen starken Willen wir geben uns
Mühe früher habe ich mit dem rechten
Bein gespielt jetzt mit Links seit
Wochen trainieren dieän zusammen viele
sind frisch
amputiert wir werden nicht mehr so wie
früher spielen können aber Spaß haben
wir
trotzdem das Team will an
internationalen Wettbewerben teilnehmen
Kostja findet sie sind auf dem richtigen
Weg wir werden immer besser sagt er in
der
teamansprache R der Ukraine r den Helden
rufen die Männer ob kosttia sich als
Held fühlt will ich von ihm
wissen ich weiß nicht aber ich sehe mich
nicht als Held ich war nicht bis zum
Ende an der Front wurde verwundet dabei
wollte ich
weiterkämpfen jetzt kämpft kosttija sich
zurück ins Leben er ist Familienvater
hat zwei Kinder seit Anfang August hat
er eine Prothese er holt sich und
trainiert in einer Reh Klinik in leevv
in der
Westukraine kostjas Einheit war in
bachmut stationiert er zeigt
[Applaus]
handyvos das hier hat er am 10 Februar
aufgenommen 200 m entfernt von
russischen
Stellungen einen Tag später wird er von
einem schrabnell
getroffen es war hart zu akzeptieren
dass mein Bein amputiert werden
sollte mein erster Gedanke war was jetzt
wie soll ich weitermachen wie soll ich
das bloß meiner Familie
erzählen sie alle hier sind in einer
ähnlichen Situation junge Männer deren
Leben sich im Bruchteil einer Sekunde
veränderte 1000 Patienten haben seit
April in der Klinik in leevv Prothesen
angepasst bekommen 500 stehen schon auf
der Warteliste genaue Zahlen darüber wie
viele Ukrainer in diesem Krieg ein
Körperteil verloren haben gibt es
nicht momentan ist mein Plan
und dann kommt das weitere je besser ich
laufen kann umso weiter kann ich planen
je besser ich gehen lerne desto mehr
Pläne habe ich wir sind bei den
superhumans so heißt die amerikanische
Stiftung hinter dem Projekt und der Name
ist Programm alles ist möglich glauben
Sie hier die Behandlung ist für die
Patienten kostenlos und fast alle sind
hochmtiviert sind junge
Menschen jeder hier hat Pläne für sein
weiteres Leben die wollen sie
verwirklichen sich um die Kinder kümmern
oder einen neuen Beruf erlernen einige
wollen sogar zurück an die
Front mahareta ist 27 ihr Mann wodimir
hat sich freiwillig an die Front
gemeldet jetzt wartet sie auf ihn in der
Klinik während er beim Physio ist für
ihn und B den dreijährigen Sohn will sie
stark sein auch im
Krieg zum ersten Mal habe ich geweint
als er gesagt hat dass er freiwillig an
die Front geht ohne dass mit mir zu
besprechen und zum zweiten Mal als er
sich auf die Prothese gestellt
hat sie hofft darauf ihren Mann bald mit
nach Hause nehmen zu können nach
hakev wir werden Arbeiten uns erholen
mit unserem Leben
weitermachen vielleicht bekommen wir ein
zweites Kind
unsere Pläne ändern sich nicht er gehört
zu mir und ich zu ihm wir sind eine
Familie in der Werkstatt der superhumans
steht jeder giipsabguss für ein
Schicksal aus jedem wird eine Prothese
ganz individuell ihre Träger werden
immer mehr auch das verändert die
Ukraine es ist wichtig wie die
Gesellschaft das wahrnimmt wie Veteranen
integriert werden wie sie akzeptiert
werden wir sprechen über die neuen
Normen des Körpers über die neue
Ästhetik darüber dass behinderte
Menschen zur neuen Normalität
gehören es ist ein langer Prozess auch
für Kostja der irgendwann mal sein
eigenes Geschäft gründen will immer
wieder wird seine Prothese nachjustiert
die Fußstellung ist entscheidend in der
Klinik nutzt er jede Gelegenheit alles
auszuprobieren im golfen ist er
inzwischen so gut dass er zu einem
Turnier in die USA eingeladen wurde
keine Hürde so scheint es ist ihm zu
hoch weil er erst mal ein klares Ziel
hat ich will an die Front zurück zu
meinen Jungs in meiner Brigade ich will
kämpfen als Zivilistin sagt er mir
kannst Du das nicht verstehen er hat
sein Bein gegeben für die Freiheit und
sieht jetzt wie schwer es für viele
seiner Landsleute ist die Konsequenzen
zu
akzeptieren
ich denke dass das Land nicht bereit ist
das Land die Leute müssen sich anpassen
denn wir sind viele und nicht wir müssen
uns an sie gewöhnen sie sollten sich an
uns
gewöhn laufen ohne Stock danach dann
eine elektronische Prothese darauf hofft
Kostja für ihn sagt er ist das ein Leben
voller
[Musik]
Möglichkeiten
ه